so the story there is I teach I've been
teaching Aikido for 20 years and so part
of our testing procedure is a
five-person freestyle for fight people
attack you and so I've been a recipient
of that and I've also been part of the
high person mob so that's what that
referred to really other quick fact
about that musics obviously Doctor Who
it's not
I know that there was another Doctor Who
theme song earlier today the story
behind this is about four years ago I
had an opportunity to be on hardball
sitting next to President Obama and so
he comes in you know introductions
what's your name I say we get the
scooped I said there's no way I'm saying
that and so for the next thirty minutes
I was the doctor
the only reference to the doctor I know
is Doctor Who so that's what's behind
that so today I'm just talk about sort
of some practical things that I needed
to do and so I get to present on it so
it's about dealing with teaching
materials and I tell I thought it was
relevant because I know plenty of people
in this room teach in different contexts
see there's workshops apparently Jarrod
can't even stay at home anymore with how
much he teaches and Mark teaches here
there's plenty of people at Georgetown
so just thinking about this
so I teach among other things the basic
art course at NIH now and this was
developed out of the some necessities of
teaching this over and over again but
before let's see if this clicker
actually works for me it does
astonishing so Who am I really big fat
guy regardless I've heard this entire
community with mark as he said nine
years ago it's grown and blossomed I'm
so happy and we can have these
conferences so story goes back the plan
before Jared came here last year we were
talking about trying to bring us are
here and we're like can we really
and then apparently Jared just analysis
in New York that he's coming today I'm
coming to DC and so we're much happier
now so I was on the board of DC Data
native community DC which Janet Abele
leads now so bite Reno a biostatistician
I work at NIH which for those of you who
are not local is about 20 miles north of
here the premier biomedical research
institute in the country and it's not
the world and I also have a startup that
I work with which is across the river
almost literally and so it's Dean so I
ask you the word data science or data
scientists because I don't know what
that means anymore so I must
biostatistician I am a data analyst what
have you some people put that under the
moniker so that's fine but the reason
I'm going to give this talk today is I
teach as I said are for the last three
or four years I teach the basic or class
at the NIH grad school and my population
of students our bed scientists primarily
so it's a very non-coding group of
people right these are people who are
barely comfortable with Excel and in
some cases which means their data
management skills or leave something to
be desired
some people are laughing because they've
obviously dealt with this so this is the
course web page they created about three
years ago and has been evolved this year
I'm not co-teaching it which is nice
which means I get full control over it
but what got me going with this is our
markdown and how you could create web
pages with it and you could create blogs
with and you create websites with it and
so this is actually I'll talk about how
sort of bits and pieces of this how this
is actually three webs three sub
websites with a cover shell why and I'll
get to why's three sub websites but the
needs are but it's creating content that
is easily available to my students can
be updated easily and from my side can
be maintained easily
so as a teacher you have to produce new
slides you have to produce homework if
the grade homework you have to do all of
that stuff the teaching involves and you
know lazy me trying to get our to do
things I think I have the same virus
Jared does where he tries to do
everything in our in graduate school way
back when I had on I was at Washington
and for those of you who have ever in
know people from your busy Washington
they don't eat fast there
it's an are set s plus school until one
year in our second year someone tried to
teach a SAS for a mixed models class and
two of us decide we're gonna do this in
our regardless so it's one of so that's
how far back I go and our so this is the
other class I teach with database but
very similar websites and then also with
workshops the point here is that there's
several commonalities here you need to
have a syllabus you to have some
structure that's overt you need to have
lectures that are updated
you need to have homework you need to
have a way of sharing resources and for
the workshops I actually have course
notes as well so literally making the
book on the subject so fornum teaching
what I'm thinking about is two aspects
there's the in-class piece that is when
I am in class so as the slides its
potential demos how do i express that
how do I show that so sometimes it's in
our studio sometimes is in a dashboard
like Mallory described sometimes it's
just interactive graphics so I can show
people so Gigi animate is another thing
I use a lot now the other side is the
research that people go home and get to
consume those are things that course
notes other resources links to the art
studio cheat sheets links to the
wonderful community of our authors we
have who are putting their books out on
the web for free which is wonderful and
I continue to encourage people to do
that but all the other side I of course
requirements right so I have to have a
syllabus that I have to submit I have to
give out homework I have to grade
homework I have to turn in grades so how
much of this can I actually automate so
I don't have to wonder about how to do
it every year and so the conceptually
when I thought about this about three
years ago said okay rough
speaking I needed a website okay I can
do that norm wrote down let's see if
this and then slides I was doing i/o
slides I got enamored with sharing and I
wanted to learn it so I all my slides
are written in sharing again for those
of you don't know it this is something
that EVG developed a few years ago I
personally like it you don't have to
like it but it's a it is why it is and
it has a lot of flexibility I like
homework I make them submit in armor
down which makes it easy for me to see
whether things work and for me to
annotate and my notes course notes end
up in book down with literally read each
chapter by chapter what the topics are
corresponding to each lecture so that's
the concept and this is pretty
straightforward I need some glue to put
this together into one package which as
I say will be an arm wagon on website
but you know every year is a little
different I preach things which means I
have to create new product and
forgetting your slides new homeworks
I have to keep this updated keep track
of things put it on the web so that I
don't have so people know where it is
and not rebuild every time so I was
thinking make maybe so something that
just updates what's new right as opposed
to updating everything this is this at
the end of 15 weeks there's a lot of
material on this website so you don't
want have to rebuild everything and it
would be nice to have some directions
some people of contents where people can
just go oh that's that lecture that's
that topic and automated processes can I
not have to look at the calendar and go
okay this date I do this this date I do
this too by hand thing and for my
homework how can you automate the
process of capturing the homework
there's people who do this in github I'm
not going to teach a bunch of been
scientists github I'm not I'm I'm crazy
but I'm not mad so it's not gonna be
github so the solution I came up with
was Dropbox actually and then there's
grading how do I do the grades as I'm
looking at the homework how can i grab
the grades and put them into a nice
tabular form that I can now submit at
the end of the semester
so the syllabus ends up being so I will
say I don't know attribute everything
but I've stolen liberally from the
internet you do some of this so on this
one there's a bunch of code here but
regards the main point is that I can
automate the dates
because I have a weekly class if I have
a start date I can have our just go boom
boom boom here in my weeks I just have
to give a vector that says what am i
doing each of those weeks and then that
just becomes a table I put it out on
cable and it makes a nice format
I know Mallory's gonna say why didn't
you do it and du/dt right sure I can do
it it's just it's just it's in a small
table we're okay
so this turns out to look like this so I
don't have to worry about the dates in
here I just need to know the start date
which is nice this is very easy this is
actually part of an of a markdown web
page where I have the table of contents
floating on the side so this just
doesn't just have the syllabus it also
has sort of the requirements the books
and learning materials academic policy
the usual pair for nail year around a
course right so the second piece I'm
gonna talk about quickly is the table of
contest and this was sort of interesting
so the table of contents from my lecture
so I'm gonna do lectures weekly I don't
want to have to go back to my arm our
dinner HTML go oh I made lecture eight
today with this title can I now put this
in and put all the pieces in the crucial
step in this is learning that I can grab
each arm are down slide I'm assuring
then right so it's our markdown I can
grab the title from the metadata and
populate my table automatically so I
don't actually have to physically touch
the table of contents the other piece
that's really useful for me was glue
this glue allowed me to create the web
links very easily and it just populated
it and you'll see I used to glue a lot
and in terms of formatting at the bottom
there's a package of cable extra which
some of you may know which puts a lot of
niceties around cable so I add some
styling to it in terms of striped and
how wide it is and so on
so forth oops and so the nice thing
about this and I'll tell you how those
links happen so you're seeing I have the
original are markdown I have the HTML
they also have a PDF version because
apparently I've got students who like to
print them out and scribble on them HTML
does not print out well typically right
and then it just automates it so BC you
can't see further done I just finished
lecture 9 this is my current web site so
it's actually published as I go along
because I'm basically using something to
process it every week when I do my
lectures same thing with the homeworks
as long as I have a folder of homeworks
that I'm giving out I use this last few
lines to automate using glue data so I
have a data frame and everything glue
data to just go you know template it out
and so that ends up getting me this why
do I give the are markdown out because
that's the template for the food you're
gonna submit back they can download the
armor don't fill it in with the code and
send it back to me and so I've already
given the temple so they don't have as
much of an overhead to learn our
markdown you know de novo sorry this way
so this was something that was really
interesting actually ties in or Dan was
talking about earlier today was
reticulate and what Mark was talking
about with about api's so the solution I
have for getting homework is using a
feature in Dropbox called I think the
file receipts so you can put a link out
and as soon as someone has the laid they
can click on it and upload their files
to a designated folder if you design
that you are state turns out Dropbox has
a fantastic Python API alright because
beauty of an awesome was there the last
six years the nice thing about that is
that I can use it I can write a Python
program that will automatically given
the parameters I want the parameters I
want are what's the deadline
what's the name of the project and what
directory that gets sent to it'll go out
using the API and grab me the link so I
don't have to have to
point and click at all right and so here
I actually use reticulate inside my are
markdown for that page for my hope for
the homework page and just grab that
function and run it I have my link and
that turns into that submission link so
entirely something I'm not touching
which I like so how do you do homework
evaluation so you know how I get the
homework so I get the homework I run it
on my computer
guess what's my friend here the package
here if you've ever read Jenny Brian you
know how she is poppin she loves that it
gives you a way of getting relative
standardized relative pathnames and so I
use that I run it then I can comment I
just comment in markdown and at the
bottom and the last line I structured
that way
I put the score so 9 out of 10 8 out of
10 what have you if I have that
structure acting use R to just grab each
file grab the last line of the of the
file I use solve the manual entry
problem I just grabbed everything now
it's a vector so the part I didn't say
here one of the things Dropbox does is
as the name to the front of the for the
submission of who's submitting it so now
i parse their name from the name of the
file i extract the score from the bottom
of the file guess what I've got my
linked spreadsheet for that homework now
there's no matter of just joining it
across the homeworks to create the
spreadsheet right so I submit the
homework and design a homework 1
homework 2 so on I can just do a map
over that entire system at the end of
the semester grab everything at have a
spreadsheet it also allows me to say who
hasn't been submitting who has been
submitting because you get blanks right
because I'm just doing left joints all
the time and so the my names are
constant so that's the parsing the last
part I don't know where I found this but
there's actually a package called Gmail
are so you can get a ga goo goo and send
g mails from our
with whatever material so what I do I
have a script now that use a GM LR grabs
their annotated homeworks I have their
names I get I have a database of their
emails right because I get that because
I'm the teacher I parse that put them
together I send emails out one button it
goes out to the entire class
I think Jarrod did that once several
years ago and I think that's what got me
if you do that for some of your posts
right originally so so that's part of my
thing that's a feedback loop that I
create that when they gave it to me
it's an hour process to get it back to
them I have not played with learn are
and greater I know Dan Chen's been
working in over the summer on that it
seems very cool it just wasn't in my
pipeline when I started this but I think
it's worth exploring is to how to deal
with homeworks and grading that making
that more automated as well so got the
processor mind to update this and need
to some make like thing so I found Drake
and willl and I was very nice and
corresponding and helped me setting some
of this up
Drake is one of many many potential
workflow management packages in our
there's a slight summary for Google that
someone has a workflow er this app
actual workflow are which has a list of
like 25 workflow management packages in
our so people have been writing it's not
prominent but it's there so I chose
Drake and Drake is written in our and
the language basically ends up being
does this actually have a pointer yeah
does so this one I for all my slides on
combined I'm trained html's right so I
rendered the the RMD file tailored for
the output directories it happens and
essentially there's some are Lang code
in there saying I have a list of the
file names process it through as a list
the next one is actually fun it's like
to PDF is something I wrote as a wrapper
is running page down the chrome print
function in page down it actually does
the best job I have found for the HTML
slides as an automatic process
so this advantages takes the my or
markdown files and convert them into PDF
slides and then the bottom the last
piece here creates the table of contents
so increase the top level web page and
so once again surrender site from from
our markdown and then there's some
triggers that happen as to if any of the
slides gets updated since the last time
Drake saw it run the top level against
because you have to update the update
the table of contents and so it's very
similar with the homework stuff I'm not
talking about the course doses today
simply because I haven't doing have not
been doing much course notes for this
class but that's just a book down site
so you write up your stuff in our
markdown run book down on it you'll get
a nice HTML page you know if you've ever
seen you know our for data science the
Headlee has online or many of them the
our cookbook the JD is JD that has it
right there version two so a bunch of
people have booked down sites so if you
go to book down dot or you'll see all of
them that have been submitted it's
basically the same format but it's
internal and I always keep an option
once again my audience there's a PDF
download version so the point and so I
said so I was doing this piecemeal and I
started working on packaging this it's
called course down it still needs work
but the idea is to try and treat a
template its structure so I have three
websites essentially if there's a
lecture site which is a site unto itself
the homework site would just slide into
itself and the notes which is a book
down site and it's wrapped around an
overall sort of front-end web page right
which has the syllabus and the resources
and the sort of the top-level
non-dynamic stuff and the assumption was
that i'm deployed on github pages so
there's a particular structure so
everything gets pushed the doc folder
and it's provides some templates for how
slide should look how the web pages
should look in the like so there i
create a course ya know file which
basically gives me that gives
you know stores the course information
so when I run my templates through the
Gamo
all of them are branded with the course
name and the course instructor and the
dates and so on and so forth so it's
very much a work in progress happy to
have people collaborate on this any move
ok so the talk today is about many
opinion a choice they made choice about
Drake and made choices about what are
markdown slight thing I'm using but it
tends to work I'd love to have
collaboration to fix the kinks but it's
possible to a lot of this automated so
all I have to worry about really is
content create the slice grade the
homework everything else just happens
thank you
[Applause]